my wife complains I say thank God it's
not women at its core cheaper to keep
her and that's what we're doing I'm
sitting in the rumble seat of a 1931
Packard roadster you want to know more
about Packard's and rumble seats well
I'm gonna introduce you to a family who
knows absolutely everything I'm Oliver
travina and this is car collectors New
York my name is Ralph Morano
I'm the oldest under Jim Renault I'm the
youngest son I'm Ralph Murano jr. and
we're in our family toy box we have all
our collectible automobiles here and
this is where we go to get away from
Arden business which is cars and these
are the cars we love more than the cars
we sell this particular car took nine
years 12,000 hours to do this was burnt
to a ball it's a passion it's bringing
back history they all got a story you
know and in the art this is a 1939
Packard Aaron these were custom built
cars they're all convertible Victoria's
this was two-door with suicide doors a
lot of these were built for the movie
stars she's probably the most radical
Lincoln in the world you don't really
know it's a Lincoln because it's really
knows and singing on it that's just so
aerodynamic and radical and probably one
of the best coolest parts of the car is
the guys I like to enjoy himself he had
a whole bar built in the back of it
the car we have here this is a 1931
Packard model 840 this was the last year
for this body style it's it's a roadster
which means it has no windows you have
side curtains that you could snap on the
side for bad weather and then this also
has the rumble seat in the back Oh must
be you yes mr. Morano yes dad Murano yes
I don't want to say anything wrong
because you booked two sons in every
room pretty baby
I don't know more Italians and your
daddy let me show you a little bit of
art this is stunning this is absolutely
beautiful this is the 1934 Packard body
by LeBaron Aero coupe 104 take a look at
that suicide doors fastened do let me
show you something from the 50s which is
called the concept car this is me this
is you this is me
don't least sit in it let me show you
something put this hidden door handle
that unbelievable so easy to slide over
as well you're hunting over over here
we've got a 1931 Duesenberg under the
hood there's an unbelievable work of art
that an engine or an engine this is
where it all began let me tell you about
this car a skank stop I'll tell you that
this is the one that started for me
thanks is your first car this is not my
first car of the sign first Packard
before the war what you drove is what
you were peppered was this iconic I
think it's kind of going full circle
because if you drive this you know
somebody you can drive it to a conjoint
you can't make these promises they're
empty promises well that's not driving
thank you so much thank you I'm your
only character in front I don't want to
put the other guys down but this is
definitely my favorite for many reasons
Ralph has a great style guys let us know
what your favorite car is comment below
and you can tweet us as well let us know
sky somewhat of a legend you could be to
start collecting thanks thanks mate
you